in our series Vlad to Dad my CBS family
is helping me prepare for fatherhood so
this morning I'm getting tips on raising
my daughter to celebrate her diverse
Heritage and feel comfortable in her
identity so we met up with our dear
friend and CBS News correspondent Ouija
Jang she was born in China and her
husband Luther is white and grew up in
the South just like me they want their
two kids to embrace their Multicultural
background
[Music]
hi on most days Ouija Jang is talking
about the white house here in Washington
but today we wanted to talk to her about
being a mom to infant Jack Lee you want
to go first and four-year-old Francis
May or Frankie who she's raising to
embrace their cultural heritage by means
of language traditions and food I think
that's such a big part of raising
biracial children is making sure that
they have an understanding of the food
that they eat or the culture it comes
from
we set out to cook a few recipes passed
down to her by her parents who owned a
restaurant while she was growing up my
mom made me a lunch box when I was a new
kid at a new school in fifth grade so
I'm so excited to eat this food and of
course when you open the lid in the
lunchroom you just hear it right some
kids don't feel like they belong
psychology Professor Natalie Brito was
born in Okinawa to Japanese and West
African parents and was raised there and
in the United States and her husband
whose Heritage is Iranian German and
Italian grew up in Saratoga Springs New
York they're raising children together
too I remember bringing school lunch
boxes or Bento boxes and having a lot of
kids tease me about that I recall
sometimes throwing the food out even
before you open it because you don't
want kids to sort of look at you and
make you feel other so I don't think
conversations around culture or racism
are that different from our everyday
conversations I think as adults and as
parents we sometimes feel like these are
heavier topics and that you know we
should wait to talk to them about these
things it may be hard for some to
imagine but as a kid I was shy and
introverted a child of immigrants
speaking French before I learned English
having a difficult name for some to
pronounce often led to feeling like an
outsider I wonder if those conversations
parents should have them with children
even before they start schools you know
it might not be sitting down and talking
about you know anti-blackness or racism
but it could also be in the form of
celebrating your own culture and
diversity and embracing your own family
heritage back in the kitchen
Ouija did just that and those dishes
that kids once laughed at are the ones
that are bringing her the most Comfort
today including braised pork and steamed
fish I'm just going to cut a little bit
we're gonna steam it Bon Appetit we sat
down for our meal joined by Luther
Frankie and Jack what were you thinking
about when you were thinking about
naming your children we actually chose
Frankie's middle name first which means
it's May Mei which means Beauty I
remember in grad school one of my
professors said you know you're probably
gonna have to change your name because
no anchor is going to be able to toss to
you in the field and say and here's
Ouija Jang and I thought well that's
their problem you did Ouija you thought
that was yeah so I never considered
changing my name we're very privileged
in the sense that you know our children
are getting to grow up in such a diverse
place like Washington DC you have to to
prepare your children for the day when
there will be some kind of crude remark
we just speaking to Jack in Mandarin
I love that I realized that language is
a gift that you can give your children
and so I am making much more of a effort
to only speak Chinese to Jack
Professor burrito supports this approach
it's actually best for language
development it's best for brain
development and kids who are stronger in
that Heritage language early on actually
are better at learning English so is
this a smart thing to do for parents to
think about this really important for us
to be having these conversations coming
from Multicultural backgrounds but I
think it's even more important for
families who might not have
Multicultural backgrounds to have these
conversations right I think
conversations around culture around
racism around discrimination are your
conversations that all families should
be having and if all families are having
these conversations it'll make it a lot
easier for our kids to kind of navigate
those experiences it's so easy to get
caught up in all the things you think
you're doing wrong but just being there
and loving that baby he is the only
thing they really need
so of course I'm Franco Haitian my wife
Marion is East Asian she's Chinese
American and one of the things weeja and
I talked about is language obviously so
we've got English to Chinese books our
French French book but when we were
growing up there were very few books
about our cultures with people centered
this is freedom soup by Tammy Charles
about the Haitian soup jamu which
celebrates Independence Day and we just
sent me this Amy Wu and the perfect bow
these are books that did not exist when
we were growing up as children and now
there's representation this book is
about being mixed yeah I love them
they've come together to make new colors
I like what we just said language is a
gift you can give your children it is
but a lucky little girl you're having